well kelly welcome to the show
thank you atlas great to be here with
you
it is an honor
you have
created very powerful content
um
distilled
the
spirit and science very well
it's
one of the things that i'm extremely
passionate about so i'm
very much honored to have this
conversation together and also
be able to
share
um
what you've distilled and also
advance
the mission
of creating more love
and abundance
unity
um
on earth
yeah
beautiful
excellent
yeah
um
and we'll have
several
conversational points throughout the
show on effortless mindfulness
the direct path
the art and science of awakening
awake awareness
we'll go through a glimpse practice
and we will share some of the action
items that locke is currently offering
including his mobile meditation program
including his exceptional books
and his youtube channel instagram
twitter all those links will be in the
bio below
would love for you guys to check them
out if this episode resonates
all right so
man
right
i feel like
the
best place for us to start is
the direct path
yeah
and
just the importance of it um what what
it is
and the importance of it
yeah
yeah that's a beautiful place to start
because
it it is maybe what's the difference
between the gradual path um which is the
more common or
uh
well-known
variety of meditation
uh
so the premise that makes it the direct
path
is the hypothesis
that
the awakeness the freedom the love that
we're seeking
isn't something that's created or
developed
it's already here
within us
and even as us
so it's essentially
who we've always been it's just
literally
subtler deeper wider
higher but
more essential so that
with a direct
approach
like a glimpse we can shift kind of
background to foreground what's hidden
comes into the foreground
and then it becomes more the ground of
our being
from which
becomes the new
normal the
new operating system
uh
which we then lose it
and come back so
just to say that in my experience the
direct path is
kind of a way to glimpse directly but
it's not instant enlightenment meaning
you don't stay there
it's
small glimpses many times repeated
so it's direct
realization but then gradual unfolding
yes
the core part of what i feel
you shared there is to
bring the
background into the foreground is a
really good way to put it um
so
let's talk about that more
so there's a
sense of
we could say
i
or beingness or presence before the name
the identity the stories
that is shared
and that we would like to bring that
background into the foreground in a
sense
yeah
and then
what
what is the direct path of doing so is
the question right
so this is i think this is one of the
most important
questions and
i'll start by saying
that even within my
particular approach there's many
doorways
so the idea is that
people have different learning styles
and they have different obstacles
that keep us from recognizing and
realizing
this essence of
our true nature or this awake
consciousness
so
there's not one way and there's
certainly not one tradition
but there are some simple vegetables
that are similar
uh
and there's a couple of
the two main ways i would say
are what's called the
the resting method
or the do nothing method right
which is kind of letting go and letting
b and
some traditions like zen call it chicken
tazo which is just sitting so the the
metaphor which i love there that's
almost like a
a poem is
uh muddy water
let's stand
becomes clear
right
so there
it shows that in some ways it feels like
a background foreground but actually the
water
the clarity is not in the background
only it's always everywhere right it's
just being obscured
by the primacy of the denser
consciousness
so when you sit and don't engage and
re-uh
re-rustle up the
the mud by
active
identification engagement then
it may settle
now
that can be direct but that also is
actually one of the main practices of
the gradual path which means you sit
that way for
uh three years or 30 years or three
lifetimes and then it may settle enough
to be able to be
[Music]
able to live from it because when it
clears the next stage is
so then it's clear but you're sitting
and you're not moving
so what happens
when you recognize it
then you
important to realize that's who i am and
then what's the relationship to the mud
so that you can get up stand up and
begin to walk and create and relate
without just saying oh i better go back
and meditate again i have to sit still
as if stillness or sl silence is the
absence
of sound or movement
right so that's one that's one method
and a little bit about it then the other
method is is more
of what i do which is
a little more of the inquiry method or
the looking method
or the
unhooking of awareness which is already
identified or attached
and having it drop or open
and
immediately
know itself or return home
to the settler dimension
which then recognizes that that's
the ground or the source from which
energy is actually made of it so there's
a can interconnected feeling
of unity or flow
where you're more the ocean of awareness
arising as movement energy then as
patterns of consciousness thought
feelings sensations sub-personalities
and then a human body
still primarily
awake consciousness
but and that's the the key is to learn
how to be 51 percent away consciousness
and then welcome everything else
right
and those two can also be very much like
one
yeah yeah
i found i mean you can start with one
right
yeah right
right
and
this is great
because it
it's important
to share that what we're
what we're describing is what we feel
like is the most direct way
um
and
there's
an incessant amount of movement
which is
um
deeply conditioned by identity and
separation and location and lack and all
of these other things
and
the
the
slowing down of those
oscillations of thinking can
bring us
more inward and that's why rest is just
such a beautiful
way to put it do nothing inquire
and
through that process
that
can lead us to feel whole
when we're doing nothing
exactly yeah
and that's so beautiful
yeah
like i don't have to do
anything to be
perfect to be the absolute to be the
highest possible
and
that itself is peace that's love
right
that's the
freedom the realization
of the kind of okayness or sensual
well-being
which has a feeling of
unity or interconnectedness
and innocence like
that it's deeper than the trauma it's
deeper than
the feelings of worthlessness and not
good enough and
subtler deeper meaning subtler and
more essential so that those other
feelings are welcome to arise
to
you so that's one of the
simplest inquiries that i have is
is to shift from
focusing on what's arising
to find what is it arising to what or
who
is this all arising to pleasant or
unpleasant
the traditional mindfulness is looking
at the contents of consciousness
noticing it's coming and going it's it's
rising and passing
but then effortless mindfulness kind of
begins
by having awareness look back
to itself look back through the
meditator
to open to the field
of already awake
consciousness that's awake without our
help
that then is arising as
the aliveness
not
not being caught in what i call the
witness protection program of
being
dissociated and looking from a detached
disembodied
view which can be a halfway
point and can be very helpful
uh transition
but just staying open and coming home
to embodiment and then
open-heartedness or
uh kind of the fabric of love that feels
there's no non-fear non-worry
non-shame
to which
fear worry or shame are welcome to
arise
and isn't
spiritually bypassed but now the
psychological healing and the
physical
releasing of
being kind of frozen
and protective
can begin to thaw out and be included
yes
right
yeah i feel
we're already
um
yeah deeply diving into
um awake awareness which is excellent
and
the art and science of the practice many
glimpses
repeatedly
and stabilization
yeah
yeah the last bit you shared
has also
been deeply resonant because there
there feels to be
a spaciousness
in the background that can be recognized
and then that can be brought into the
foreground and then that can feel like
love for everything that
is and
so then that sort of that duality
collapses
but it's it can be a helpful
duality at first
um
i found that to be also very powerful
yeah and it it then becomes a
multi-dimensional
uh reality meaning
that primarily there's a
uh
you know a pure awareness that's empty
or void or
infinite and then there's
a unity or love
that's interconnected with everyone and
everything and then
there's these unique waves of the ocean
of
awake consciousness which are
particular individuals that have
personalities and
and and then can see each other
uh with integrity and
respect and
equality you know almost naturally if
you're looking through the eyes of the
heart
yes
nice
yeah and i've known noticed that you
also
speak of it like a simultaneity
right
being across all of those domains at the
same time those dimensions
yeah
and then that
helps us be
as you've said aware of distinction and
unity simultaneously
yeah and that that's very powerful
because it
it's a very holistic
perspective
because it takes into account the
the traditions of
unity
and love
spaciousness and yet at the same time it
takes into account the beauty of the
individuation yeah
and then
seeing
all
um
from that makes it so that when
individuals interact or engage they're
coming from that
unified love and yet at the same time
the unique expressiveness
yeah
and uh yeah the messiness of being human
is just part of the grist
for the
you know that isn't
uh
doesn't have to take over but it has to
kind of detox or thaw out because of the
conditioning and
the not only our own personal
conditioning but almost like ancestral
just passing on generational
uh cultural
uh
that that can begin to um
liberate but the liberation often
as it moves out takes over for a while
like
you know anxiety fear
and then it's like
so that magic move
of effortless mindfulness once you've
done a practice sitting still
to be able to unhook or what i call
unhook but
let go
and actually have awareness step back
into that which is spacious and
pervasive
to be with
what's arising from a
more holistic view
loving
self with a capital s if we use that
language
then whatever parts of us that are angry
or fearful or
traumatized
are
beings held and welcomed
right as they throw a tantrum
and we're not acting
out from them but we're not repressing
and acting in we're actually letting
our full
humanness because we've discovered that
the
open-hearted awareness is the capacity
to be fully human yes
nice i'm so happy that we're
on this
healing thread
yeah
so
by recognizing this open-hearted
spaciousness
we can
fearlessly and courageously lovingly
spaciously be with anything
anything and all of our conditions
and it can be hard to look at many of
the conditions
um
but in doing so
we
love them
into dissolution and integration and
transmutation and
and freedom greater freedom
yeah
and there seems to be nothing that i
found really more powerful than that as
another huge part of the direct path is
that yeah exactly if it comes back so
that's you know the beauty of you
what you're saying both the direct path
and the healing so
discovering the awake consciousness
which is
unhooked or detached in order to be more
unified and
and embodied
while remaining
infinite and intimate
yeah that's great infinite and intimate
that's that's beautiful how important
healing is on the direct path yeah
so important for us and for everyone we
engage with you know just to realize
when you hear someone's story
you can't believe it if they those who
like they look like they have it all
together or something and they just
start being honest you're going like oh
my god everyone is just carrying around
all this stuff
right and
most recently it's been very beautiful
to
recognize that those are each
individual's treasures
yeah to look at it their own time
so there's like no urgency
uh
there's no
need to generate a catalyst
right
it's just
timeless
for them to look at that unique treasure
inside
just yeah just to be able to
show up for
the unfolding
so not pushing the river but not
you know kind of
staying underwater too much
you know so that you see where and feel
what's going on
as whatever the next
thing that's ready to
to come forth for
you know to be heard and met and
and loved up you know
yes
yes
and it's
it's actually a really
it's a really beautiful way to
to share
that the direct path can be both this
very
like powerful
direct inquiry
uh into the nature of reality and
identity
um and yet at the same time it can
really be this
like hey i i feel
a deep
trauma in my life that i would like to
look at and i don't necessarily know how
to and i would like your help
in holding that open heart space while i
do
yes
and
that's another
way
it is and you know that part as you say
it beautifully you kind of give a lot of
space to that you know because it can be
with a
friend with a therapist in a group
that's a supportive group
and but it's it is that kind of finding
a safe
um
you know
same same but other person other human
being that you can be feel listened to
and you can kind of get that out
so at some point you know whether it's
therapy or
coaching or
or a good friend or two or three if you
need as you go along
uh to tell your to tell that story it's
not to tell to have those parts of you
that have been hidden away
to let them be heard by another
and then ultimately
the one they're looking for is you the
one they're looking for is
that you that's not you that's
bigger than you
it's essentially you
that has no self that's
a self
whatever that is
that paradoxical great feeling of like
wait a minute this isn't me it's bigger
than me oh but it's the
source of me
that's that's that feeling that can't be
put into words
that's where a lot of direct path get
gets caught it's like oh it's not oh i'm
out of duality i'm pure awareness
and now
life is just a movie
playing on the field of awareness coming
and going it's like
okay keep going come on back you know
because it's
not a movie it's actually
an ocean of life and
connection
that you're in it when you're in it
you're
[Music]
you still have that support that's
bigger than you and then you can be your
be your unique
uh personality um
that's just the flavor of the wave you
know right
hmm
right
another
uh powerful way that i've
seen be a
common approach
has been
sort of using
the mind to
study the symbols of what
i
is
and then
anchoring
in the body
in that interconnected oceanic unity
uh rooted earth basically
um yes
so say more about the symbols like
say more about the
first part of that
as though
my mind understands the symbols right
right so there's like a
there's like an endless
uh possibility space of imagination and
symbology
and there is
it's very much
mirrored by the internet let's say right
okay and it's a big
um lots of hay and very few needles okay
yeah right and so by using the mind to
look and find the needles
of what i is
yeah try and identify them put them into
maybe some notes or a distillation of
sorts
across the ancient wisdom traditions
modern science things like that yeah
that's it
and then
embody it
which is more about the heart and the
root just as an example
so then everything can come
you know online like that and it feels
different when everything's online like
that that's been really recent
for me is coming more online like that
and sometimes it can show up a bit you
know a bit
like primordial it can show up a bit
uh and that feels great too
no that's great that's gotta gotta have
that juice you know um you can't you
know that's what one of these little
side eddies of some of the spiritual
maps that start to get people caught as
if oh i get it you're not supposed to
have any emotions okay oh that oh let me
try that you know and then it's like no
no no don't don't do that you know maybe
when you detach from over emotionality
you'll have freedom from it and you'll
be in a kind of observing
uh accepting place but then
when you come back
you have you're still open and you have
you start to what i call shake and bake
you kind of get this kind of fullness of
juicy life uh but what you're describing
sounds like yeah as i was saying there's
different doorways and paths like in
hinduism
the jhana path which is the path of
knowing or knowledge sometimes it's
knowledge but it's like you're doing
looking to the
you know your consciousness is going
from gross to very subtle to really
and then it just drops in in from the
mind in
to with consciousness within which is
connected out so that's that door
which is a great door yeah
right
ah
it's just it's really warm it feels
really good just being together feels
great
this feels like a
good time to explore um a glimpse
practice as you were sharing there's uh
doors
yeah
there's ways to access we were talking
about the direct path through all these
different facets of the diamond
including healing or yana path
so let's go uh
yeah let's do this
yeah so i it feels like there's two if
you don't mind i'll do one now and one
later that almost complements it please
so
so this one um
okay i'll start with kind of
we were at the second one but i'll go
back to the first one so when we started
we said
that often the
the mud that settles is kind of
conditioning
and
kind of operating from
important but more gross level uh
physical
emotional mental
and missing and those three physical or
mental emotional mental form a self a
small self
that
is trying to survive as a separate human
being which is important since we are
animals in the world and there are fast
moving objects and things like that so
but that overly
uh
dominant definition and training and
conditioning
uh can cover over
what's already here behind more open
subtler
non-physical non
emotional and non-thought based
so
the little small self tends to
orient by thought going to thought and
creating this little thinker
and doer and
problem solver to try to be safe so it's
probably trying to you know what's going
on out there is there any problem out
there is there any problem in here
what's going on out there is there a
problem out here
so that problem solving
function as we get smarter
and more
more successful it actually gets
stronger
so one of the main obstacles
to people who really
actually
learn a lot and grow a lot
is their strong
problem solver ego center their small
self
so if that can relax
we might be able to feel
kind of a more subtle
not sleepy and not thought-based
alert
awake consciousness that's more spacious
and pervasive
so that's the premise that's the kind of
description
so here's the little inquiry
that is being asked both to the problem
solver initially but actually is a
invitation to the awake consciousness
so the inquiry is
to look with understand with thought and
then look with awareness to feel
what's here now
just now
when there's no problem to solve
just understanding the words
and then not looking to thought
but letting the problem solver relax
and then feeling that
which is aware
when there's no problem to solve
and then being
aware of it
and then what's it like to rest as it
as this
and thoughts can move but just not
getting on the train
and then resting as this
awareness
what's the relationship to vibration
sensation
thought emotion in the world
without going back to create a problem
solved
what if everything's included from this
more spacious
alert
non-thought-based
and yet flow like a flow consciousness
it could move your hand
you could use thought
but then you could let your hand go and
you could
let go of thought
and have
clear peace of mind and you could
respond
to something if you needed to in the
world
so that's a little
glimpse practice that goes through
some of the stages of
awakening
from
awakening to awakening as
and then
awakening as being
so good
ah
i'm curious if
if this
are you familiar with uh papanka
papancha sanasanka
[Music]
is very much this weaving or this mental
fabrication and and then this nibbana
is the cessation of the mental weaving
or the fabrication
yeah and
and so that that that has been such an
instrumental part i feel also of this
as what you just described through this
glimpse practice
what happens when we just
slow down that fabrication and that
mental proliferation about our sense of
self and our identity and sense of
others and the past and the future and
all of that
and then when we just rest and we rest
and we relax back it's just
and then i love how you said that there
will be some arising but it's not taking
us off of out of that that's right yeah
and then the more that we just feel that
and then bring that into
right
bring it in
bring that in and then
that
is lovely
is conceptual proliferation is from the
pali language and
one of the kind of linchpin
sutras between i think
uh
insight meditation or theravada or
gradual practice
uh to direct practice because it kind of
gives one of the linchpins as you were
saying and the thing is
even nirvana is not
um
as from the direct path isn't
eliminating
from more of a tantric direct path it's
not eliminating the
thoughts it's just
that you don't get on the train and you
don't have to orient to thought that
thoughts are like
mental sensations
being observed not by a thought-based i
think therefore i am that's the key is
it's the thinker more than the thoughts
thoughts are not a problem
the brain actually from neuroscience
doesn't stop no matter how quiet you are
it's going to be active
but we have a habit of
not only
paying attention
but then forming
a thinker
and
uh
you know from there whereas when you're
in a flow state
uh it's higher consciousness and you can
respond
faster without orienting to thought
without creating an ego center
so that's the feeling
and then it feels like there's no
thoughts but they're actually
kind of gone into the background
so one of the examples i use i ask
people like if you bring your awareness
to the bottom of your left foot right
now
and just feel the nerve endings
and all that sensation that's there
like
so you know if you can feel that yeah so
a minute ago it was in the background
but if you had a habit you know which
pain often
you know chronic pain will give you that
habit but if you just started paying
attention to the sensations in my left
foot how are you doing today my left
foot's fine and my big toe is a little
better than yesterday but my other toes
are not so good but
then you'd be
whereas you're
if you just
let the
sensation in your right foot and the
mental sensations in your head
go into the background
and then the key is awareness of
awareness
so instead of awareness of thought which
then
creates thought going to thought
you unhook awareness of thought which is
the first
mindful move of awareness of thoughts
coming and going so now you're aware of
that that's half step
now be aware of awareness
and then as then rest is awareness and
then as that awareness
notice
the arising and the interconnection
and the unity with sensation thought
feeling
and the world
so there's kind of a
awareness behind you within you in front
of you and aliveness behind you within
you in front of you but where you're
aware from
is no longer either
the small self in the middle of your
head nor a mindful witness
that's watching contents
you've kind of discovered
kind of dropped open and included
this new um
open mind open heart
to
infinite intimate you know
feeling of being so that that just that
description that sounds like oh well
that's
boy that sounded a little complicated
well you know what it's about six moves
it's not that it's really not it's new
it's unique
it's it's it's like a little weird you
gotta go what do you mean awareness
awareness then awareness is aware of
itself
then it you know it's like okay
that that i don't know any of that
that's true you don't know yet but
it's it's
it's fairly simple it's not easy it
takes what it takes but
it's available it's learnable it's
teachable
it's almost a necessity at this point
in our uh evolution and
human development
perhaps
let's see if
if this
um
way of describing also
resonates
you said that there will be another
glimpse practice that we'll do
so is
describing
the
the
the obsessions
with
identity
and
all stories
can sort of be at least from
i've also
understood it seemed like a little a
barbie house
and that the
relaxation of the story and of the
identity is sort of
the ability to begin
seeing
through all eyes simultaneously or
seeing as the whole itself
being that
and then it was seen that the
stories and identity of the barbie house
was beautiful
and it served
typically as the drill sergeant
of awakening suffering
and then
from
this
[Music]
from this realization one can then
recognize that
the way that
like you described flow consciousness
that one can
be that and live from that and express
as that
and
and then that can hold space for all of
the other barbie houses
um
yeah
i hadn't used i hadn't used i must have
bet i hadn't used barbie houses as one
of my
main images but that's good
so
so you know one of the unique things
that having come from
uh
being at the same time training as a
kind of
consciousness meditation
person and
and a psychotherapist
is kind of bringing those two worlds
together and then adding neuroscience
and
other things but so currently the
the internal understanding is that this
awake consciousness when it comes back
and then that problem solver
isn't the center the ego's isn't the
center
the self isn't the center but it's not
like there's nobody home it's not an
empty barbie house it's not an empty
the actual
ego that was trying to be me that was
trying to solve problems is an ego
function that was trying to be an ego
identity so it doesn't need to be killed
doesn't need to be gotten rid of it's
not
that it is relatively
uh it's relatively real
it's ultimately not real there isn't any
solid separate self there but it's
functionally
uh
can be part of the team
so once you realize that the all the
characters in the house
uh are parts of us
you know the the part that
uh you know the worker bee part the
judging even the you know the critic and
the judge
are all trying
to
find love they're trying to help
they're just confused and they're
burdened with these kind of
ignorances or misinformation
and but they have energetic value you
know they they have life
and they can be you know we're kind of
multiple
uh sub personalities once we're
but the key is who who's aware of them
has changed radically so that changes
but then we come back as you say the
house is still
here we don't have to keep acting like
no there's no me
i go to the grocery store
and things end up in my cart and there's
no person named locke there's just you
know which i've heard and i'm like what
is it in your cart they said things you
tend to like or is it all cat food and
you don't have a cat you know it's like
you
if you don't unify then you're
kind of dissociated or
spiritually bypassed so finding a way to
understand and to feel
all right what is happening
here so this
sub personality or parts based
psychology seems to go very well because
then you can have
you can start to feel anxious and go
all right where am i feeling anxious i'm
feeling my throat all right well where
is it located is it in my head am i no
just like right here all right can i
step back and be aware
of that anxious part of me
and then say oh part of me is anxious
okay
and is there a part of me that's not
anxious yeah there's part of me that's
excited about what's happening in this
part of me
that is fearful this part of me that's
like it's all going to be all right
so
you are aware of these parts of you then
that one part
doesn't
you know
possess you take you over
as if i am anxious i need to try not to
be anxious
i better go meditate and not be anxious
like okay we'll just step out in a
direct way
be that which isn't anxious and notice
this isn't anxious
and now
don't
make it spiritualize
it away just like okay stop being
anxious because i'm
truly the non-anxious
awareness
then come back and say who's anxious
what part of you thanks what are you
anxious about
so it's almost like being with inner
children
so then they tell a little story because
they've been holding it
and they're trying to
you know tell the truth
and if we can then start to
meet that and listen and be with then
they just relax they start to go like
all right well uh you know nobody's
listening to me and i'm saying okay i
hear you that nobody's listening well
nobody's listening me okay i'm here
listening saying hearing you say no
one's listening and they're like
all right so you're listening it's okay
yeah so it starts to
um
be this relationship with
those parts but even the you know the
rageful parts the panic
hateful
are just like they're just
have something to say they were hurt
they were right
you know they need to be heard
right yeah right
right
it's really powerful to
have
non-resistance to the barbie house
to have healing to the barbie house and
then that is what then
unwinds those
conditions and contractions
i was doing some yard work today and i
was uh noticing resistance to the yard
work oh
there could be a a more
uh
rich expression of the universe right
now
through this
vehicle then yard work
and then there was the the relaxation of
that resistance
and that was all that needed to happen
in order for
this to become the yard work itself yeah
and that was peace
yeah that's right yeah that's
the uh that's the that's the process
once you have access which is why the
direct
path
i feel can be done
you know certainly in the midst of doing
everything else and growing up and
but once you have access to that then
when you get gripped
by something like a resistant part
that's like
i should you know like a spiritual ego i
should be doing yard work in a spiritual
way that makes me feel and then you just
go like
all right well
that's
an opinion thank you for sharing yeah
all right
yes oh
great
is this good time for the second
sure
yeah glimpse excellent
so
this one is uh
i'll do a little story because there's a
little neural science in it but
uh
so in the like the first
uh neuroscientist that studied
meditation a guy named herbert benson
who
wrote some books he was a harvard
professor so he he went over to tibet
in the end of a three-year retreat with
a big group of tibetan monks
and he brought all these you know they
had like these uh
suitcases and and uh huge containers to
bring all the equipment over there they
did this eeg
on the monks and that you know which is
like this bathing cap with little
nodules on it it's the way they measure
it
so he sets up and he starts talking to
the young monks who are pretty much in
their advanced stage of the last part of
their three-year treat
and he says
okay now what we're going to do is we're
going to take this cap with these
nodules and we're going to measure your
meditation we're going to put it on your
head and they all start laughing
and then he's like the head monk is like
now now please respect these western
scientists they've come from far away
you know it's like okay okay so so when
we measure your meditation then
they start laughing and then finally
they ask what are you laughing about
is that when we experience meditation we
experience it here
and here
in the heart space
we don't we experience this as empty as
gone
so
they were saying you know in terms of
our experience you may be able to
measure it there but that's not where
it's happening it's happening
we've dropped from head
to heart mind
body cheetah
so this meditation i kind of
picked up on that and it's called
dropping from head to heart space so
the premise from this direct practice
approach is that you don't look down
like you would watching your breath from
your head using your attention
uh to your chest or your belly
that literally you
have awareness itself as as identified
with thought unhook
and decenter
and then feel as if your awareness is
aware of your jaw and your smile
from directly from within direct
perception
then feel as if your awareness drops
into your throat and neck and then drops
into your body and then behind your
heart space into your heart space so
you're aware of your heart space from
your heart space so that's the
description
so now that's just to give you a sense
so you don't have to listen to much to
my words you can just kind of feel it
so the sense is that
i'm talking not to you the ego or the
meditator or the intention attentional
one who does things well i'm talking to
you the awake consciousness
which is identify with thought and you
can move yourself
down
because you're aware from everywhere
already
so this is the premise
you don't have to feel it or know it or
believe it but try it let's see what
happens yeah so just feel that sense of
uh seeing
and hearing that goes to the center of
your head to feel that sense of
identification or
normal sense of seeing consciousness
hearing consciousness thinking
consciousness just find that location
of where are you hearing from where do
you see from where you're thinking
and then just notice the premise that
awareness
is what thoughts are made of and
awareness is identified or attached to
those thoughts and awareness can simply
unhook and step back
into more open primary space and then
from that openness awareness can
actually
feel your body directly from within so
it drops from head
to
your smile and your jaw
and see whether you can feel
this shift so you're feeling your jaw
and smile
directly from within
then feel like a globe of invisible
awareness
whereas if
the
center is dissolving you feel
dropped into your throat in your neck
just feel that aliveness
space and awareness
direct perception
and then feel as if awareness can move
itself and drop below your neck into
your upper body
and just feel your body as if perhaps
for the first time directly from within
the awareness within your body from
which your body is made
just drop
open
drop below and behind your emotional
heart
until you find this kind of
safe heart space
this
heart mind or this
and then go deep like into a
river and then into a space within
the atoms
so that you're aware
of your heart space you're aware
from your heart space you're aware as
your heart space so it can even kind of
open up back
through the middle of your body
and start to become aware
back behind you of the awareness that
has you back
so surrender that globe of awareness
back
at the speed of awareness until it
discovers
the awareness that's already aware
and like an ocean of awareness
that
is becomes dancing aliveness feel that
awareness
is equally spacious and then pervasive
as your body
and then feel uniquely as if
you're almost looking out of the eyes of
your heart
so your eyes are like periscopes
receiving information goes down to your
heart mind
and then can interconnect it with every
thing and everyone
without projecting without analyzing
just
being
seeing
dropped open and including everything
connected to kind of a boundless heart
that connects to your whole body
top to bottom but doesn't relocate in
your head stays dropped
so see what that feels like and you know
certainly you can try it now and then
but see if you can kind of
try it when you're taking a walk
sometime like drop and then just walk
and just feel the
nature or just simply
you know do an activity that
feels like you can stay dropped open
behind you kind of in a panoramic way
and then
receiving with your eyes opening
open
in this
wisdom mind this
it has discrimination but not
uh
judgment in its
negative judgment
discriminate
gorgeous
it's powerful to use the word soma or
somatic in
contrast to the mind
because it it it feels
so much like it's
it's it's
yeah yeah
right
and from
from
from here you know and then that
right
fullness of it yeah just like that
yes kind of the
chi
the chi when it's more like
chi than then kundalini kind of goes up
the channel but this kind of opens like
the wings of the heart kind of
has the same
but it doesn't stay too
too tight yeah
opens that up but it opens this up too
so that you have right oh that's great
oh that's great so there's a
there's
like a wings of the heart
and then
there also feels to be a
rooting an earth thing
from dan tien through the back of the
spine
almost sometimes through the leg but
sometimes not even through the leg
almost like your spine goes in the
ground yes
just like
and that's the earth you know
our
source and then and then you can be
aware of all that because that's the
area that has certain repressed a lot of
repressed yes
like for sexuality right
hunger trauma power
so you need needs
the the infinite and then you need the
open-hearted to go down yes
how does it go right to the
to the belly chakra the
root chakra it's tough tough work
because you're just it's stronger than
any ego it's to
blast you
out so
finding this resource then you find its
its power because it wants to be
liberated too it wants to
do its natural thing about power and
sexuality and
hunger and it doesn't want to be
confused and
wants to be life force life force
natural natural
right
i've also
recently been
feeling
like the the breath the breath itself
rather than being
in
some symbols and concepts
very shallow breath
that there's this
there's like a rooted
heart felt
somatic
yeah
sourcefulness to the to the breath to
feeling that
oceanicness and waveness
um
and
a powerful
for me and i've seen this is
a very powerful one
um
down here
down here to have as we unlock the
fearlessness and the courage to look one
of the one of the powerful ones is uh
the relation of
this
to all
yeah right so it's self-image
is one of the most
subtle ones let's say to to look at and
investigate and transmute any lack
separation um
desire to be seen validated
unworthiness
yeah that that that feeling of you know
the heart is the center but it has to go
down and up
like often people feel the the ground of
being
like
right here at at the beltline it's
almost like
like
and that's kind of the connection
between in and out so it's not so much
of a chakra or a energy center it's like
literally the
inside and out of the same the world and
me are connected
right here like
right and then there's you know more
energetic
stuff going on but that's
a place to rest the ground
ground quality and then i ask people
usually by doing something go out and we
come in and then it's like well how do
you feel and someone will say grounded
and i said where do you feel grounded
like they often go here or
everywhere and i say well what's the
ground made of
and they go what's made to the ground no
no is it like made of earth
they go like no not earth like what
i don't know it's really grounded
it's really safe
it's really okay
like never before it's me it's
like oh it's made of
awareness it's made of nothing but not
nothing like
oh awake nothing
it's made of
the infinite that's here
all right
so that's the you know that's the thing
it sounds like i mean i hope people are
getting this if you haven't gotten it
it's it's not it's not that weird it's
not that far foreign and far away it
really isn't it's learnable it
definitely is learnable
um
it's just subtle like you'll make your
own words to it the words
you know
or the pointers that we're describing
from our experience
are one way to kind of get a sense oh
okay i'm in the territory a little bit
i'm a little like this it's not like
that
but then finding a door and a
direct
way to have that
awareness be the knowing and the knower
of itself and then of energy and then of
your body
most people have known it they
in fact you know that flow consciousness
i often use i say
what do you do in your free time that
you love
you know and then people are like i walk
in the woods i garden i play with
animals i play with children i surf i
dance i
paint uh you know i say well what if you
did that in order to get out of yourself
and into a more interconnected field
called awake consciousness
like it's not about the thing
or the activity
that's the door
what if you didn't focus on
the hill you're climbing
and getting to the top and looking out
over the at the sky
what if you then
looked at the sky got that feeling and
then felt back who's experiencing this
and then what if you could access that
any place any time
because you know the door you already do
it in fact you're you're compelled to do
it and you call it fun
right
nice
yeah
but you don't know that you know it
you think it's about
you know the person who plays music can
find it the other person
who um
you know goes surfing like the person
who goes plays music may not get it when
they're surfing the person
you know because that's not their door
it's not about surfing or music
it's about
something
that allows you to drop into that
out of the ego
into the interconnected field that's
subtle and knowing and highly functional
activities totally isn't just sitting
still
but has stillness
to it right illness yeah right
as though it
it brings
the realization of stillness into all
movement in a simultaneity yeah that's
right
ah yeah
well
just beautiful
yeah
yeah it's so beautiful i mean that you
know that first question resonates again
like what is the direct practice and
you know is it how do you do it and
that's that's what i've been like about
like what is it and how do you do it and
then how do you share it you know how do
people
other people get it because the water's
so good it's like the water's great come
on in
because
when you taste it it's just like oh my
god so many people say
i can't believe this has been here all
along
and nobody ever showed me how or oh now
i remember how
i naturally experienced it but i didn't
know that's what it was
right
right and there's access points which
can feel like
pre
is some in some ways pre-18 months
of age
that baby like innocence
uh another one
can feel like
the saturation of god's love
being
omnipresent um
so perhaps a sage-like wisdom
um
perhaps a bit of like
reptilian or primordial chimp-like
playfulness and groundedness
and
and
that
yeah and
to
have
this
available
as a
mini faceted
access points
to the diamond that's right here always
right here
um
it's gold
yeah it's cold
yeah the the the
the awareness-based
knowing
is what's just coming to me so we're you
know
talking about that term i use awake
awareness
it just means that it's not attention
it's not
it's not um
uh
you know i am
aware of something it's
it it's a awareness that's already awake
and alert so
it's alert without using thought
because it was alert in the 18 month
year old
baby and it's alert
uh post
you know using thought and in a flow
consciousness it's alert and functional
and then
the
implicit memory can just be a program
that is used as needed yes but that
that's the new uh operating system nice
it's awareness-based
primacy of awareness not
thought and thought is made of awareness
so we're not getting rid of thought
thought is useful our hands are useful
our emotions are useful
right
where are we operating from and you
described
each of those facets the ape-like one
and the you know the love and the you
know each one has the awareness because
you've shifted into the
awareness-based knowing and then the
aliveness will come out in different
expressions right right
i love that
so
open
spacious
and then pervasive that that a lot and
then that alive expressiveness through
and i love how you brought flow
where
were
whatever
is that activity that is sought after is
just the cessation of the identification
and stories
because it's
it's dissolved into
the very is-ness of what is hap and
um
in a very highly functional way now yeah
yeah cause you're still so good i mean
steph curry is shooting and he's not a
separate person he he you know it he
that is it's the very
three-pointer happening
itself
and
the violinist or
the gardener or the hiker or whatever
the activity is is that
that is f and it's scientific as well
which yeah i wanted uh
to just bring to
recognition as well which were
at least
let's see if this is aligned with you as
well that it seems to be the cessation
of the default mode network and the
activation of the central executive
network the flow network um modulated by
the salience network
yeah it well it's interesting because i
was
there's a
i was part of a research project at um
nyu with uh zoran joseph polvik is the
scientist
and what he
considers what it is is the balance the
balance
of the default mode network and the task
mode network
are both simultaneously on
so what it seems to be at least from
this
this theory
that we have this alternating two
alternating networks that alternate
about every 20 seconds they look out
and then 20 seconds they look in
so in terms of meditation so certainly
you know that in terms of distraction
everyone knows that but when you try to
focus on your breath which is a task
about 20 seconds in if you start to
really look at it your mind will wander
well what is it it's because you're not
concentrating no because the network
just alternated now it's gonna it's
gonna look
it's looking out now it looks in to
daydream or to thought
um and then you have to 20 seconds later
you'll say oh that's right i was
meditating bring it back
and here's the interesting thing when
you do one pointed
meditation focus on your breath you
repress the default mode network
and you just put on the task mode so
create a kind of calm but it's a
repressed calm
so here kind of comfortably numb
calm
and then it can't last when you try to
function because you can't function
function from just external because you
have no creativity so default mode has
creativity
it has a
kind of an inner life to it so what we
did he had us a group of us who are able
to do this
more
buddhist non-dual which is equally
balancing
outside and inside or
task mode internal and what showed is
that
instead of alternating the networks were
both on at the same time right
so then what happens is when you feel
that they're on
you feel this evenness
or this uh continuousness of unity yes
this sense that oh i'm aware of what i'm
thinking and i'm aware of the world
and they're both kind of the same
they're both
have this
this section
and they're very soft and they're very
kind of happy and flowy
so
perhaps a
way to
express it is that there's a tremendous
amount of
our day-to-day
intelligence that is
in
the weaving or the fabricating which is
an excessiveness let's say
compulsiveness in the rumination default
mode and that
the direct path or the inquiry
um into inner kingdom of experience that
that
is the
toggling
inward into perhaps the concentration
the
um that central executive network
his ability to focus
and
that through that process then we can
target what is the subject what is the
background what is the nature of this
and then
finally
upon sort of recognition
um we can then
have that very much that between those
two
both lit
up and there's a equine equanimity
there's a flowness
so i'm no longer i'm no longer competing
to
um to kind of calm down
the bar the barbie house
that's um yeah because if you get lost
in the
default mode network you can be in
daydream and past memories and flooded
by trauma and
worry and trigger and if you're so a lot
of people go into work mode
and become workaholics because then
you're just
avoiding the
the default mode network right
asks over and over again and even some
of the you know the phone is going down
the rabbit hole yes
outside because you're avoiding the
inner yes the world exactly
and so so the feeling of when you're
when you balance the two and when you're
aware from
open-hearted awareness is you're not
aware from your attentional system
you're actually feel like you're aware
from the field yes
interconnected with the object
like it's over there
but there's some connection to it
through this
ocean of awareness
and i'm aware from
here
to the to the you know from everywhere
um i'm not aware like a flashlight right
intentional system uses a flashlight
my mindful witness uses like a
floodlight
to watch thoughts feeling sensations
this is like a
ocean yes
ocean connection that
is
has a panoramic feel so even it's never
connected there it's always connected
i love this
this is so good um
i
i
i've also
shared how there's an
obsession with the with the devices
and they can be so helpful for us to
recognize what's happening which is the
obsession on the object and then we just
trace back to oh well there's a
perception happening and then well what
is the perceiver what's the subject
itself what are other subjects
and
through that like inquiry process which
i think the social dilemma was a great
um
catalyst to see that
um
and then like you described there's uh
the there's like this witness version
there's the flashlight version the um
observer yeah version of the arising
some passings and then there's this
collapsing of that into
there's a field there's a field that's
aware
and and the weird thing is this kind of
trips people out there and your body and
is arising in the field
so you're not it's not coming from you
going that way it's like it's everywhere
and your body's like a wave in the ocean
and so i'll do what so you can use your
attentional system which everyone's
pretty good at and bring your attention
to an object
and then just leave it there
and let your attentional system like be
okay that system is doing that now
have awareness
turn around unhook and be aware of the
space between you and feel the space
between you and the object
and now have awareness
feel back through
that which is above your shoulders
until it feels the awareness that has
your back
and now if you're doing anything
you're resting back as that awareness
which then discovers that there's a
field of awareness
that's already effortlessly mindful
effortlessly aware
of your body
and the object
and that's just been happening all along
but we've been trying to concentrate
trying to focus
trying to get the default mode to
cooperate and meanwhile
there's a bigger system available so
that
that move scientifically hasn't quite
caught on
but i feel like i want to make that like
the attentional scientists get that like
for 80 people with add adhd
that i've taught a lot of people
individually how to focus from the
embodied open-hearted field
because it's easier to focus from the
flow
and
i think it can become
more
just normal
there's
the
there's the birth of of from the
holistic into the contracted that is
then
seen to be contracted through inquiry
released back into the hole
and
that seems to be a great mechanism for
this intelligence to
um
fall asleep wake up play with itself
endlessly
yeah
yeah
yeah so fun you know so it's that
getting used to just recognizing
realizing
uh familiarizing the the tibetan word
for
meditation is familiarized
so once you recognize you realize just
familiarize then lose it no big surprise
just me recognize right it's my little i
love that small glyph this
right familiarize
it forgot no big
losing no big no big surprise just
re-recognize
who's in no big surprise just recognize
right
right
yeah beautiful lock so so nice
ah
thank you
yes so welcome very good to
to connect with you and geek out with
you and
so deep you know go deep in and let
other people kind of hear a conversation
between us that should share that just
us being us
talking about what we love
what we experience and trying to
imperfectly articulate and
communicate with each other and
hopefully others
can hear a little bit of that and be
inspired
to give it a try
yes
yes
and
i found uh
i found a lot of uh love
here between us it feels really
beautiful
thank you
and i
um
i feel like it's
been
successfully
emanated through the conversation and
that
there are
um
there are an
awesome amount of ways to engage if you
guys would like i mean first we would
love to thank you thank lock for coming
on the show
thank everybody for watching also
and
um we would love to hear from you so if
you guys want to
drop a comment below and let us know um
what resonated
um
you guys can always like the video
and share the video if it resonated
that's a powerful way to
continue spreading
this
um
you can subscribe to our channel you can
also subscribe to lock's channel his
youtube will be in the
bio you can find a lot of great free
content there also on his instagram and
twitter those links will be in the bio
you can find all of his books
on his website we'll have that link down
there as well i highly recommend the way
of effortless mindfulness and also shift
into freedom just powerful reads
direct loving you can feel the love
in the books
[Music]
and
also you can find the affiliate link to
effortless mindfulness to the mobile
meditation
um
and give that a go i've been playing
around with it and it's very direct what
lock shared with us through
the
the glimpse practices
is just dived into even more deeply and
regularly so give that a go check that
out
and
anything else locke
no i think that's it um
you know i look forward to meeting
people and
just to invite people to give
this direct path
a try it's so beautiful
there's many different ways there's
other teachers other you know don't
feel like there's only one way
keep trying because i find that people
are like
i don't know
no
no
oh
oh
whoa
whoa
just stay with it keep trying different
door try this door try that door right
then don't try any don't just don't try
at all right
hopefully
you'll be in the in the soup you know
you'll be in the yes yes and it'll find
you because it's already here that's the
main thing it's already within you
it's already who you are it's just a
little covered over
and we're finding out how to drop or
open
let go turn over
but
what is it that let's go and what is it
that let's go into
and then what is it that includes
everything that
exploration is
uh is possible and
just really
quite extraordinary
yeah
and then what does that recognition
bring forth into
our world how much more
love peace unity prosperity abundance
for all is possible
it's all we know it is we know we know
it is but we like to play the game of we
are separate from these other people and
that we would like more for ourselves
and that whole game and um
but the pie can grow for everybody from
a place of unity and love and we know
that that's uh where where it's all
heading
yeah yeah it's for this is not an
individual you know go to a cave or a
monastery this is literally let's awaken
together in this world and and live and
then make
responses and compassionate activity
that flows naturally from this
uh clear seeing and
courageous motivation yeah
yes
excellent and
i feel i feel powerful uh within
continued exploration with lock and the
effortless mindfulness uh institute as
well as offerings so i'm really looking
forward to that and just
cross-pollinating our networks and
super excited for that um let's go ahead
and wrap uh the recording and then you
and i just for a moment can stay
together lock okay
all right thanks everyone we love you so
much bye
bye everyone